[Music]
a man
his death and a story that shocked the
world and shook america
[Applause]
george floyd and what happened here is
now so symbolic of an age-old american
struggle
a grief and a grievance still far from
we resolved we did that for our
ancestors
this place has left its mark upon
history even if there's work still to do
for the floyd family that brings comfort
and pride amidst today wrought with
emotion
i think if we had just had him pass away
or
die and nothing happened as a result of
it
it you know it would have felt like it
was not worth
the pain and suffering and don't get me
wrong i definitely wish i could have him
back but since we can't
this is nice to be able to see all of
the people who are in support of us
what was once an ordinary junction is
now a community space
while crowds gather for events to mark
and remember some like rachel have lived
here all year
with peace comes power and presence a
lot of people's protest is not big and
loud
but it's showing up and it's gardening
and it's coming and playing
you know under the people's way with
your children it's community it's
conversations
for all the carnival atmosphere there's
attention here too this is now
a sacred space where police aren't
welcome and for many who cherish and
guard it what they really want
is institutional systemic change that's
the legacy that will really matter
president biden agrees he invited the
floyd family to the white house to
discuss it
they'd all hoped police reform
legislation would be passed by today
if you can make federal laws to protect
the bird
which is the bald eagle you can make
federal laws to protect people of color
say his name george floyd
we got our space and we're gonna take
the air lasting change will be hard
fought but the eyes of the world are
watching now
as they were one year ago the challenge
how to ensure what happened at one
ordinary intersection can deliver
extraordinary change
in america helen and smith sky news
minneapolis